bonjour avis tounkara merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu après l annonce de washington sur
la levée des brevets l'union européenne
s'est récemment a dit prête à discuter
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'afrique
on savait que la nouvelle a salué mais
quand on rigole quand même avec
l'apparition de la comédie nef dans le
continent naturellement certaines voix
très légitime aux voiries humiliante
avec un des projets l important de saint
aignan de cliquer il y aura donc en
somme si le gameplay le continent
africain
nous avons des hommes et des femmes
majoritairement qui émettent des suées
doute quand
quant à l'existence même en 2009 en
dépit des sites du tennis est là et il
faut quand même aussi le rappeler le
continent africain en bonne partie
notamment l'afrique de l'ouest beaucoup
de populations penser que l'occident
c'est dans une sorte de conspiration
c'était dans une sorte de complot afin
de les bus davantage les populations
africaines lorsqu'une telle pandémie est
perçu de là il m'a les soirs que même là
les vues si vous voulez la possibilité
du bébé accordée aux états africains
vous pourrez difficilement avoir un
impact positif de la bulle est justement
victimes car vous vous parlez de ces
doutes un de la part de la population
africaine
récemment la république démocratique du
congo a renvoyé près d'un million trois
cent mille doses de vaccin vous parlez
de cette réticence 1 de la population
africaine
quant aux quant au vaccin comment
comment on peut l'expliquer justement
les raisons sont simples bien sûr que
vous avez des religieux qu'ils soient
musulmans ou chrétiens qui avaient émis
des doutes quant à 10 ans déjà
justement de la maladie dans lé même
temps vous avez aussi des personnalités
très influentes qu'elles soient du monde
artistique comme aimant du monde
médiatique qui ont aussi à l'aise pour
inciter les populations du pays
toutes ces raisons font pas aussi quand
également locustes et la gouvernance de
façon générale elecam béquille donc
cette pluie de confiance à la vie
politique africaine respecter le aussi
le pourquoi les dix ans auquel les
populations font l'objet vis-à-vis des
septiliens sanitaires mais pour faire
simple le continent africain pense que
illégal quand même le nombre de
contaminés c'était bien rappeler moins
de 5 millions les personnes contaminées
sur le continent d'ailleurs le cas le
plus courant c'est un lycée plutôt
marque canalisée vers la mission dans
les autres parties du continent estime
que les sept communes 19 laisser les
pays natal africaine donc pour d'où
toutes ces résistances à n'est pas
surtout se faire vacciner
elle appelle également ses ennemis et
ses différents vaccins
on a vu un l'apparition du variant
indien
notamment en eau parce que justement ce
variant indien peut potentiellement
inquiéter un peu plus en tout cas
l'afrique
pas du tout parce que quand vous
regardez un peu les cohérences également
ses buts ou ce fossé entre les élites
politiques africaines à et les
populations
ce sont des facteurs qui sous-tendent
aussi le pourquoi du déni ce sont des
facteurs qui expliquent le progrès
également de cette non prise en compte
de cette mise au sujet de cette pandémie
mais je pense pas que ces différentes
formes la paix les vaillants pouvait
amener les acteurs
moi je veux tellement aller ou voir le
rapport à la commune de chances que peu
importe l'état diligence et un parte
l'apparition de nouveaux variants
édifice immense croyances et du ciment
c'est l'apport gouvernement gouverner
elle pourrait être changée dans un délai
aussi court donc en somme nous allons
continuer à assister à les apparitions
médiatisées de la part et religieux de
blogueurs ou de certaines personnalités
influentes en demandant aux gens surtout
de ne pas se faire vacciner parce que en
acceptant de se vacciner et la probité
forte d'avoir déçu d'y avoir d'enfant en
acceptant de se faire vacciner
beyer la vaccination l'occident cette
chaire est réduit de façon drastique les
populations chrétiennes
donc lorsque des clichés des préjugés
ainsi vite une quotidienne des
populations
il n'est pas évident et toutes les
initiatives qui sont aujourd'hui ce
crime à la fois par leur nation la santé
est pour l'instant en bêta africain
merci beaucoup aux lettons gayral avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue et
directeur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sel à
merci beaucoup